[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar compliance considerations when
selecting a gmp compatible freezer
i am marie stone of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dean
rainbolt technical applications manager
cold storage division thermo fisher
scientific dean you may now begin your
presentation
well great
thank you marie i appreciate the
introduction and i want to thank
everybody for joining us today
i know everyone is stressed on time and
uh so i appreciate the attendance
um hopefully today
we're going to learn how to purchase a
gmp freezer
so
i think what
the approach will be
is we're going to purchase this thing
together and we're going to go through
the different steps um if any uh that
that we might want to take to purchase
the correct freezer for gmp
select marie said
this webinar is compliance
considerations when selecting a gmp
compatible
freezer and
so again we're going to act like we're
the customer and we're going to try to
figure out
at least one process to get this done
successfully
so if we have never met before my name
is dean ray vault and i am the technical
applications manager
for the controlled temperature
technologies
group at thermal fisher scientific now
i've been there at thermal fissure for
about four years actually a little over
four years now before that i spent
a little over 28 years in the
pharmaceutical industry
i was a asset
manager for analytical testing labs
reference standards laboratories and
storage applications there development
stability sample operations and just
general uh laboratory applications as
well
i participated as an audit team leader
in a subject matter expert so that's a
really
uh
floral way of putting i was
the guy on the hot plate when the fda or
someone else would roll in and want to
perform an audit in in our organization
and i also was an internal audit person
so if you don't do internal audits
that's a whole
another talk but
in internal audits are very important
um
i also did the asset management um i'm a
member of the international society of
pharmaceutical engineering or ispe in
isbur the international society for
biomedical and environmental
repositories
both important
if you're in the business of storing
samples
i do have strengths in equipment
validation and qualification that seems
to be a passion of mine and
and i've authored
a couple of temperature mapping uh
protocols and procedures so
also i'd like in the wings i'm going to
have some support uh in the question and
answer period i have jason chen who's
our marketing develop manager he'll be
uh available uh josh lewis who's the
senior product manager uh for our
fisher connect platform as well as sarah
estrella
with
that group as well
so i have lots of support today
if i can't answer your question
hopefully we can get that done
so let's talk about the agenda
how hard can it be so we're going to
talk about considerations before
purchasing a freezer um
where do we start
are are there requirements that you need
to go by and is there any guidance out
there
what's the plan
maybe a plan is a design qualification
and
what is a design qualification
what parts are involved in a dq
and we're going to find out after we try
this dq process we'll we'll figure out
if that works for us
and then we'll conclude it and
get the question so
before i get started i i want to be very
transparent and let you know that
i was that guy
who
the lab manager came by and said hey
dean we need to order a freezer
and i'm like no problem what kind of
freezer and they said at minus 20.
i said okay so i opened up a catalog i
picked one and i bought it
well then i got it in and i had to
qualify it
well that wasn't working out i just
couldn't get that thing qualified it
just wasn't working right it was very
close
but just wasn't getting there so i
reached back to the manufacturer and
asked about you know what was going on
and well
i found out some stuff about ordering a
freezer and we'll get into uh
a little bit more about my experience
later but let's move on
how hard can it be to order a freezer
well i have to say it's a little it's a
little harder than
uh opening up a catalog and checking out
okay minus 20 that works for me
a lot things that you need to think
about
is what are your business needs and are
they global
what regulations are you going to follow
what's your sample storage strategy your
strategy i mean how do you move the
samples around how do you store them how
do you retrieve them
how much storage space do you need
that's important because i in my
experience i never had enough storage
space
now do i need backup storage space so if
i have a 30 cubic foot unit sitting over
here and it fails or i lose my
monitoring system or something like that
can i move them you know what am i going
to do with my samples
now does the freezer need to be
qualified
if it does how are you going to test it
what's your testing criteria
what utilities are required and you know
we're talking about electrical uh maybe
the temperature surrounding the unit
because if you store it you know if you
put your
freezer in in too hot of a room that
could cause issues with the performance
of that freezer
and uh location now go ahead and laugh
that i brought that up but i've seen it
before
folks will order a freezer and they
won't look at the technical data sheet
to see how big this thing is and when
they get it off the dock they can't push
it through their laboratory door so you
need to to make sure you get the right
size
and then do you want connectivity i mean
do do you want a solution of uh having a
system that helps you maintain the
health of your your freezer and then do
you need external monitoring which
you know if you're in a gmt application
you probably do
so a little help please i mean come on
that's a lot of information and i'm not
sure what parts and pieces of that
that i'm gonna have to use
so
let's
let's take things one step at a time
here
so what are the requirements or or are
there requirements
so first things first you have to
determine
what are your requirements so this is
something
that a vendor manufacturer freezers they
can't they cannot answer this question
for you you have to know
what your requirements are
so in order to figure this out you need
to involve your quality team and the it
team if needed so here again
i know i heard you guys groan when i
said quality team
because we know their job is just to
slow us down and make things hard right
well that could not be further from the
truth
you need to get these guys involved so
you can address all your issues
beforehand
because you don't want to go through
this whole process and then hand them a
request to purchase a freezer and they
look at you all funny and you have to
start over
so you also want to benchmark internally
so what are other
areas in your group what what are they
doing
how are they handling
their freezer and sample management
you also want to benchmark the industry
so if you're new to this you want to
reach out and talk to people about what
they're doing especially folks that you
know are getting audited and have audit
results that they might be able to share
with you
now some ways to do this is to join
scientific societies like the you know
like i said before ispe and isbur
uh these are very good organizations um
they have guidelines like the isp has
controlled temp chambers the
commissioning and qualification
uh mapping and monitoring guide i keep
that handy because i'm in it all the
time
and then the
isburg best practices recommendations
for repositories um they have a fourth
edition out
um
these are very good places to
uh take a look and see what's out there
to get a little bit of guidance
there's some other groups out there like
the
pharmaceutical stability discussion
group um
that's a little more focused for
stability applications but folks like
that
they do
in their uh bi-annual meeting they go
out and they'll share their mapping or
their uh
audit
opportunities that they've had and share
some of that information so all this
knowledge is super super important
so now where else can you get guidance
okay now once again i have to stress
this is not something that that catalog
you know there's nothing in the freezer
catalog that's going to answer any of
these questions
so where do you look for more guidance
well i personally in this case
let's look at the fda q7 good
manufacturing practice guidance for apis
or active pharmaceutical ingredients
and they say
qualification because you know i'm going
to have to qualify this thing
before initiating process validation
activities appropriate qualification of
critical equipment
and ancillary systems should be
completed
qualification is usually carried out by
conducting the following activities
individually or combined so i'm gonna
i'm gonna make you
wait on on exactly what those are just
for a few minutes so i'll get to a
little more on that
offering of a regulation in a few in a
few minutes
so now we're going to need a plan
so
we think we know what the requirements
are um now we're going to need a plan so
one way that i found works well
is a dq or a design qualification
and that's part of
an instrument qualification package so
the the design qualification in this
case
is and this is as specified by the fda
it's documented verification that the
proposed design of the facilities and
equipment so there's the keyword
equipment which is our freezer where
systems is suitable for intended purpose
so that's what we need to concentrate on
so there you have it
there's a guidance out there that says
hey maybe using a dq is a good idea
now they also go on to say
that they'd like to see an installation
qualification an operation qualification
and also a performance qualification but
we're not going to get into those right
now those are all
separate discussions but if you do go to
the fda q7
you'll see those listed as well
so now here's an example
of a dq now
i
these are kind of fuzzy at least they
are to me
this is just to kind of give you uh uh
a quick visual on what an instrument
qualification form might look like and i
know it's hard to read we're going to
get into parts and pieces here but it
just it goes step by step from the time
that you decide you're going to
pick a unit
and it goes through some steps until
your quality unit will sign off on it
now i'm not going to cover anything
further than the dq
today
so let's look at the parts of a dq so
there's a change control and if you're
working in a gmp setting
uh you're familiar with the change
control
i won't go through all of this but the
important part here is that there are
there are six primary stages the one
that we're going to concentrate on is
the equipment installation and
validation and cal work or the
calibration
that's what we're going to focus on
so in this dq you're also going to
simply put down the instrument type in
the manufacturer so you know we're going
to say all right we need to ultra cold
freezer and we're going to purchase it
from thermal fissure
and
the user requirements now
this is one of the most important parts
of a dq
this is what's going to sell it
to your quality unit
so it's kind of what do i have to have
and what do i what would i like to have
so intended use what is your intended
use well okay today our intended use is
for storing critical samples because our
samples are important
and we want the desired temperature of
minus 80 degrees c
all right easy enough now special
requirements ranges of operation
performance tolerances and capability
requirements
well in this case i'm actually going to
refer to
the usp
just for this example and the usp in
their general chapters
they say that
if you're going to store samples colder
than minus 20
you're allowed
plus or minus 10 degrees c
movement
of the recommended storage condition
okay so my test acceptance criteria is
plus or minus 10. now i'm also going to
need about 30 cubic foot and i'd like
some visual alarm notification
that's just what i want i also and i
didn't put it here but i want some
connectivity as well i mean you know if
there's something out there that tells
me that my
my freezer um may need to get looked at
or maybe ready for some maintenance
ahead of time
i i think i would like to see some of
that and also external monitoring that's
kind of a little different we'll cover
that here in a minute
now another part of the dq is the
instrument design
so cots or commercial off the shelf um
that's the one we chose that's um we put
a check mark there because i i don't
really need a customized uh freezer of
any kind you have we have three choices
we can just use it as recommended by the
vendor which that's what i usually
do
sometimes it requires some customization
and sometimes you know here's a box for
custom design so you're gonna have to
pick um i must tell you it's so much
easier to use
yet
commercial off the shelf because then
your manual
will provide you the information on
proper use and it will also give you
some information about preventative
maintenance and things so if you can go
to that
um
that that's really going to help you
show that you have control
over that so now let's go to the
the design qualification and
verification so based on the vendor
recommendations and specifications
or based on custom design documentation
you want to verify
that the intended use is within the
nominal instrument capabilities
you also need operating ranges you want
to verify that they're within the stated
instrument capabilities like we talked
about before
the intended physical operation
environment needs
meets the manufacturer's
recommendation
you need to check out the utilities and
the facilities make sure they're the
proper stuff is available there
and also computer components are
combative compatible with your network
environment so not you know in that
whole quality group and your it group
you really need to be on board with
those guys before you order this freezer
now here's some really
neat
um
very critical
documents from the manufacturer these
are the technical data sheets and i know
that this is kind of hard
to see
but
this is the thing that when
i asked my salesperson
hey
here's my requirements on this freezer
what do you got that's going to fit
well their tool they're going to go to
the tds
and the technical data sheet it's going
to cover things like what application
can you use it for
um
what temperatures
uh will work
uh what temperature range is there what
kind of power do you need
um there's just a slew of information
here usually the first couple of boxes
will take care of
what your needs are
but then
the
the
equipment qualification form will also
guide you to talk to your building
facilities folks to make sure that
the facilities needed or the utilities
needed for the freezer
are available or can be
available so
you don't want to buy something you know
if you have a 115 volt
receptacle you sure don't want to buy
a 220
unit so
tds is a
very very important part
of our decision
to purchasing
this freezer
now in this case uh
well this kind of captures it shows a
little bit better what i was talking
about there's application storage volume
temperature ratings
things like that refrigeration system
that can be important um you know
make sure it's energy star compliant
talks about compressor
things like that
and it will also go into what kind of
refrigerant is used and things like that
flammability down here
now also is performance so remember you
know we have to be plus or minus 10
of our
desired temperature so
here at the bottom of the
technical data sheet it shows some
performance
testing that was done at the factory now
keep in mind
the factory that they'll never know how
you
or let's say us right now as a customer
is going to test this
freezer so they have no idea so
what the factory does is they figure out
where to put probes so they can ensure
that this freezer
can operate to within the specifications
that you want but keep in mind if you go
to map this chamber with your own
protocol it's probably going to look a
little different than this now the
operation
that won't change but these numbers will
definitely they won't be the same but
they'll they'll be within
your acceptance criteria
now other considerations
that i want in my freezer is remote
monitoring and if you're in gmp you're
definitely going to need that
i need to
and i can't remember which regulation it
is offhand but
they say in a stability
uh
operation that you need to ensure that
there's a
24 7
data or a collection of data
and
so you're going to have to have that
when you have remote monitoring it
provides operation
operational efficiency compliance and
quality it answers all those questions
here's improved science results and and
part of the reason that that's out there
is because if if you're looking at your
monitoring system and even before you
get an alarm if you see that you want it
to be a little tighter or something like
that or if it's not performing exactly
right you can go ahead and put in a work
order to have it looked at
sample security is also another one this
thing is going to you know remote
monitoring tells you
when the door was opened how long a door
was opened
things like that equipment optimization
of course like i mentioned before it's
going to tell you uh
you know show an indication
uh that the freezer is running correctly
and of course that's going to give you
peace of mind that everything's fine so
you know that's uh
in this case
we want remote monitoring
so let's see
now everything that we looked at with
that tds
and all the information per the
regulations that we looked at
we need to
double check and make sure that this
freezer fits our purpose
so
desired temp of -80 yep
that that's it
do we have enough space for storage
well i didn't focus on it on the tds but
this particular freezer has about 28
and some change cubic feet
of storage space so that's close enough
for the 30
that i was looking for
the testing criteria doesn't meet the
testing criteria well the range
that i saw on the graph was about
uh had a peak variance of around four
so
that's plus or minus
2 sort of so my peak variance is 2
that's plus or minus 4 so oh yeah that
very well meets the plus or minus 10
criteria that i needed
now
does it have visual alarm notification
well i didn't focus on that but in this
case the unit
um it does have a sound
that comes out of it and then you know
in case of an alarm and there's a visual
alarm notification in this case it's a
light bar at the bottom that lights up
so like if it's working right it's green
if it's
kinda not working right it's yellow and
if it's an alarm
um
it'll show red and probably you can set
up a sound
alarm as well
and does this one have connectivity
absolutely it did so
we're looking good so far
all right
so now what do we do
we have answered all these questions we
the first thing that we did was develop
a plan
um and the plan was to
include our quality and id groups
benchmark internally and externally
we've decided to
use a suggested process called a dq or
design qualification
we fulfilled you know we filled that
form out and we figured out that
everything worked out fine for us
in this case
so
now what do we do now it's easy
let's buy it
so
we've covered all the steps to make sure
that our samples are going to be safe
we have
plenty of documentation
showing
that the
uh
the unit is going to operate within
our temperature
and that we should be able to qualify
this thing with our own protocol
so the bottom line is
will it fit
in this case yeah so we can go on to
that qualification form
in the dq part
and
sign that off
take it to our quality unit and say hey
we've done our homework
this is what we're going to use it for
this is the information that we have to
purchase
or to prove that this thing is going to
work for us and
and
so your quality unit will probably be
more apt to
to let you buy this thing
so now what happened to that freezer
that i purchased um in the beginning of
my career
for that laboratory
well i guess i'm at first i was a little
embarrassed but i became a hero in some
sorts
because i had to go to my facility
manager and say hey
i've got this freezer i can't use i have
to order a freezer that fits the purpose
of my business
do you need this freezer
and he was jumping up and down and they
ended up using the new freezer in the
break room
so
i was the guy for the first couple of
years of my career known for getting a
brand new freezer for the break room and
uh that was a feat that the facility
guys wasn't able to do for several years
so
anyway it didn't hurt at all
okay so the conclusion
is
there are many ways or processes to
purchase the correct freezer
so in this case we use the
dq again this is only one example
um there are many ways to do a dequeue
or there are several processes to use
but i usually try to use the guidance
that is out there especially by the fda
and other auditing bodies
they really tell you what form you know
and what format they want to see the
information
so again i can't stress enough we
planned ahead we involved our quality
team
you also need to
include your it folks as well
now i'm going to put my auditor hat on
just for one moment
so when i would go and audit
internally or even externally
the one thing that i look for
specifically
was do you have control of your business
and
how i would determine that
is the documentation that backed up all
of the answers that you give me
so for example
if i would say
hey
what are you using the freezer for
and you would say
well we're storing our critical samples
in there and
it's at minus our desired temp was minus
20 and we got
our
minus 80 and and
our acceptance limits on our testing
protocol was plus or minus 10.
my next question would be well my
goodness well how
how do you back that up you know how did
you determine that
and then you would say well we looked at
some guidance issues through the fda and
we referenced the usp
and that fit
our business
so we went to our quality unit
and we put a strategy in place
to do that
and the same could be said about
monitoring systems
um a good question that i love to ask is
what is the temperature
of your freezer
and the answer
that
is the most popular
it comes from
one specific place so hopefully
you have set up your strategy document
if it's a monitoring system
external monitoring
to be specific
you want to make sure that
you only have one place
to get that temperature
you can have backups for that and that's
appropriate
but if you give two answers well maybe
the display and maybe the
the monitoring system well those two are
never going to match
so that's that's probably not the best
answer and you might want to think about
how you're going to answer that question
so that's it
i hope
this was helpful
i know in the beginning people think oh
my gosh you know how hard is it to
to order a freezer i found out it's uh
it's not hard
but it's a little complicated
the first time to make sure that you do
it right and that you fulfill all your
requirements
luckily
i became a hero in the break room
and then because we didn't have a really
robust process to purchase a freezer
after my
ordeal
i wrote the process and
to be honest that process in
some manner is still being used today
and i i think i wrote my first one in
1996.
so
anyway um i would
like to thank you very much for your
time and i will open it up for questions
thank you dean for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
so let's get started
our first question is
what regulations should a gmp laboratory
follow
okay
uh fair question um
the hardest part about being an
applications manager
is not being able to answer a question
with a very specific answer so in this
case
like i mentioned before
you have to
um
determine ahead of time through
benchmarking uh
internally and externally and to figure
out what is your business what are other
people doing in your business and then
you can start
uh going down that path of what the
regulation should be and if you if you
follow if you go to the fda for guidance
and some of the other organizations that
that i mentioned that should get you on
the right path
oh thank you great thank you next
question
where do i find the test criteria for my
storage application
well the test criteria that's
kind of the same answer
the test criteria you need to
set up testing or to write your protocol
based on what makes scientific sense to
you
so i i refer uh i usually have folks
write what i would call a strategy
document
uh to start with so once you've done
your benchmarking and you've done all
those types of things
um
uh then you would uh
kind of get to that point
um of if you're going in our case we
followed the usp guidance which said
plus or minus 10. so that's what we used
now
a good example would be let's say you
have plus or minus 10
but now your scientists came back and
they said oh i don't know if that's
going to work maybe it should be plus or
minus 9 because something that could
happen
to our product then of course you can
tighten that down and justify it in your
strategy document
so thank you
great thank you
next question
does a lab or company need to consider
the international regulations if the
stored product might be sold
internationally
that's a very good question
the answer to that is absolutely
um
when i was doing stability
when i was managing the stability
area
we were global just like reference
standards was
so
it took us quite some time to go through
and look at every place where we're
going to sell the product or where that
product was going to go for testing
manufacturing or whatever packaging
maybe
and
you look at the rules and regulations of
each country
then you
combine all those and what we did we
picked the worst case scenario
and so we used that worst case
but we did reference
all of the other regulations in our
strategy document so it was quite a
lengthy
process i think it took about three
folks
to be honest to get it all right and
approved about six months
to get that done
so
yeah great question that's that's a
tough one to get okay
all right thank you
next question which specific
connectivity solutions can help with
complying with monitoring regulations
yeah well there's
there's a bunch and i'll start off
and i'll take it from the customer
standpoint and then
i might defer to
uh josh and see if he is make sure i
caught everything but uh
the first thing is an asset manager i
i'm gonna want a unit
that will
let me know
before it breaks
so if this thing starts acting a little
funny
if someone gives me that information
ahead of time before it goes into alarm
that keeps my samples safer longer so if
there is a problem i can move the
samples and maybe put a work order in
before anything ever truly goes out of
whack
the other thing the temperature
monitoring
piece
that's critical i mean you you have to
have that in a gmp setting and it has to
be robust and qualified and of course
you have to be able to to calibrate it
periodically
so
to me you can't you can't do gmp
without some sort of connectivity so
josh do you have anything to add
thanks dean yeah i think i would add um
a couple points
uh when we talk about regular
regulations in regard to monitoring one
of the most important facets of that is
the complete audit log an audit history
so a lot of um monitoring solutions some
that are kind of built into systems and
aren't independent per se
they may not have a complete or robust
enough audit log with with traceable
features and i'm not necessarily
speaking to a 21cfr type of compliance
but simply an uneditable version of that
audit history is really key for any type
of
record keeping on top of that
kind of to what dean was alluding to as
well
when it comes to the validation aspect a
lot of remote monitoring systems can
also be used to really um with
multiple sensors for example throughout
your cabinet to give you a better look
into how your cabinet is performing over
time and maybe um help you preempt a
failure out of um
validation criteria within the given
year or standard operating window that
you're looking at so kind of having a
glimpse into how is your freezer
performing over time and not just at
your regulate regular cadence of
validation
revalidation windows so it's
something to consider there as well
great thank you
next question
what happens if the freezer is not
performing as intended
ah well
i'm just going to i know you're not
supposed to assume but i'm going to
assume that your
monitoring system is telling you that
it's not working correctly
so
in most situations you've already had to
set up and if you went through the whole
qualification form it's going to make
you address your maintenance schedules
and what to do in case it does fail
let's say you get an alarm the first
thing you would do
is
respond in your monitoring system
accordingly and then
all hands on deck you would go start to
troubleshoot the freezer so the two
things that you would do the first thing
i would have my service folks put a
nist traceable
temperature standard in there and see
what the temperature really is make sure
your monitoring system is working
properly so i always tell people you got
to figure out who's lying to you um so
or who failed and so you determine right
away is it my monitoring system or is it
really the freezer if it is a freezer um
because it's 30 in my case it was 30
cubic feet
or less for stand-up
applications i would always have backup
units available so
if the temperature
was not what it was supposed to be i
could immediately move my samples out of
harm's way and then of course you would
have to update
the
uh
your inventory log of course but then
that starts a whole process of
hey your samples are safe now you have
to document that they're safe and then
you put in a work order
to find out what the problem is
so
great thank you
next question
do you have any suggestions for backing
the power up or responding to an event
in which a power outage occurs
ah
okay so
uh backup systems uh is actually a class
so
i'll i'll touch on that just a little
bit um
backup power
you have to remember um
if you're going to back up a unit you
should probably have what we would call
in the business a disaster recovery plan
and in this case a disaster would be a
loss in power and what i
do and what was
used in the business is very common is
we would use backup generators on the
building circuits that our critical
storage units were attached to
now
we provide
battery backup for
the display
and in that case um it would not the
refrigeration system wouldn't be working
but
it would keep the display collecting
data and uh
when the power did come back on
it would start back where it ended you
would still have your set point it would
still operate like that now we do have
some units that have a ln2 backup system
these are not really made to be
qualified you know like mapped but it
does allow you some
time
to respond to a failed freezer if in
fact it does
fail so
like i said back up that's a whole
class
so i hope that helped
great thank you
next question
what is oh sorry
no i i just wanted to add um one thing
we talk about backup systems or backup
power you have to be really
conscientious around what type of
power supplies or backup generators that
system that you're using with an ultra
low temperature freezer specifically
because of the inrush current of the
refrigeration system so when you do that
make sure that you were conforming to
the technical data sheet that same sheet
that we referenced with regard to
performance of the unit there was always
electrical specifications on that sheet
if you don't
if you don't match it accordingly
you could basically
have a non-functioning backup power
system
okay so just make sure of that
oh no yeah thanks for that
thank you
all right next question
what is a typical lead time to order a
freezer and please outline the timing of
the whole process the purchasing and
qualification
ah
okay
so
the lead times
um from
the time that you decide to order a
freezer
and you start the process and you've
never done it before but let's say you
have a the qualification form already in
hand it's pre-approved by quality to do
um if if you really move quick you can
fulfill
the
dq portion of that and get the freezer
ordered
probably uh
inside of a week
depending on how fast your business
moves i mean if you're going to a
manufacturer that supplies all the
information that i talked about the tds
sheets and end-of-line testing and
things like that then that information
is going to be very easy to acquire and
to staple
uh
to the back of that
um
lead times uh you know we're all in hard
times right now i honestly don't know
what the actual manufacturing lead time
is
but that would come into play right now
as well
but by the time you get done doing the
paperwork
and you order the freezer you go through
the qualification aspect of it it
arrives on your dock
you get it qualified
it's not uncommon for this to take
anywhere from four to six months
it can go less
if you have everything in place
everything's ready to go
um
but i've never found that to be the case
in in in my
in in my experience actually so i don't
did i cover all the aspects of that
question
yes i think so
okay yeah thank you
okay next question
can we use 100 ethanol to store our
digital probe
so
sorry i hesitated because that's a very
loaded question
or not
um just for the simple fact
that
um
i can't really comment on putting a
probe in ethanol
i personally have never done it
back years and years ago we would put
our probes in glycol or something
similar to buffer alarms
most folks are getting away from that
now because
most regulations state that you store
the product in the condition of minus 80
so they do not want the condition of
glycol at minus 80 or ethanol
um
so i i have to be honest i can't really
answer that i i i'm not sure which probe
uh if it's the monitoring probe
um common practice in the businesses
that i've been associated with is to put
your monitor monitoring probe in the air
and then if you're worried about
buffering alarms uh during the
qualification you would do an open and
close or open door
study
to simulate
retrieving a sample let's say
and then you would take a look at what
happened to your
freezer temperature
i used to do a one minute open door
study so i would open the door open up
the internal doors
for one minute and then close it
and then i would see did it go back in
spec in 10 minutes did it go out of
specs at all or
and then
i would add a little time
and that way you could set what we would
call alarm delays
uh
in your monitoring system so when when
the unit would go out of spec
um once it went out of spec the clock
would start
what was common on all temps
except for
the ultra cold was a half hour
in my application and that gave us
plenty of time to open and close the
door
uh to get the samples so
hopefully i answered that question
hey dean can i chime in
absolutely
so it might be beneficial when when
you're asking that kind of question to
look at the various standards in the
market one primary example that has been
used at least in the industry for the
last few years has actually been the
uh the epa energy star test procedure
which might be a good reference point as
to how you monitor our or kind of
weighting you would use on your probes
in that standard when we do that
practice it's actually a 50-50 uh glycol
and water solution um the alternate
method to that is using a similar
thermal mass a lot of um a lot of the
industry is going to a copper or a brass
type of
solid material with the same thermal
mass as that 50 50 glycol water solution
effectively that's that that's the
thermal weighting that you're looking
for
okay great thanks josh
and it looks like we have time for one
more question
i know a ups backup won't supply enough
power for the freezers in the event of a
power outage
what is the best way to prevent loss of
power or recover from such an outage if
only depending on a generator
okay so
are you
i'm
assuming
that
you're running off of building power and
then
the is the question
[Music]
that that you have a backup generator
available
or are you just running on a generator
so
if
in practice if you i'll take it from
both aspects
if
you have building power already and you
have a backup generator in place
usually
that that turns on two ways it's usually
automatic with a switching mechanism at
the electrical box
so if you lost power it it's only a
matter of a second or two that the
generator kicks on and takes over and
then it would you would have to manually
switch it back over once the power
became available
if you are
in a situation where you're running on a
generator
um
you would either have to have another
generator
uh or
a separate you know someplace else to
store the samples so even if it's
offside i know it's not uncommon for big
pharma companies they'll have backup
generators but not only that somewhere
close to them will be
a
a business
that
all they do is have
storage temperature
available you know
so so you can set up a contract with
that in case of an emergency
so i hope i hope that hit
the direction go ahead josh yeah no i
was just going to add um
regardless of whether on mainline power
or on generators one thing to think
about is if you have more than one
laboratory equipment device whether it
be a ult freezer refrigerator or
whatever
when that power is restored or in the
time it takes for a generator to kick in
you're going to have equipment coming
trying to come back online or powering
up all at one time that's a huge amount
of current that's going to be pulled
from that generator one thing that you
can consider is a lot of devices have
the ability to set a delay timing so if
you have for example three freezers in
one room you could say set freezer one
to come on back immediately set freezer
two to wait a minute and set freezer
three to wait two minutes that way you
don't have that dramatic inrush of
current all at one time and you can
stair step your lab to come back on
power that would help to avoid
additional power loss or equipment
failures once you do experience a loss
of power
that's great and
that just made me think of another thing
the um
in the application that i had in the
laboratories
the engineers that
managed the building would only allow me
50
of the generator space
um
could be used just in case a lot of
stuff started up at the same time so
yeah that's a that's a good question so
thank you all very much i appreciate
that
great well thank you dean do you have
any final comments for our audience
well sure um
again i'd like to thank you for taking
the time out of your busy day to attend
the webinar um you know it's a passion
of
mine
to talk about uh my experiences and
things like that so maybe folks can not
have to to purchase all of those
break room freezers to start out like i
did and also
if you have any questions
later you can contact me
at
dean
thermofisher.com
and if i don't know the answer as you
can see i have plenty of expert help
that i can go to to get those uh
questions answered so that's it thank
you very much
well great thank you again dean for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye
you